saw for the one when you see jigsaw
jigsaw between sauna three and saw four
we've seen about twenty minutes of some
form of brain surgery or removal movie
thinks we need to be subjected to a four
minute autopsy just so we can see that
John swallow to tape that somehow makes
feature saws possible no reason to get
to the main plot anytime soon
sauna three waited thirty minutes and
the last movie Hoffman was listed in the
credits as a forensics officer and now
he's a lieutenant in what a matter of a
day or two come the gamma dish he
couldn't just do something simpler like
post dating an envelope and sending the
tape to the police precinct why even
write that on there if you find a tape
in someone's stomach I'm pretty sure
just for curiosity's sake you're gonna
play this out of that tape you think
it's over just because I'm dead luckily
predicts all he found at least one
person who not only survived his traps
but actually followed his rules later
his other two Protege is Amanda and
Hoffman became miserable failures why is
he so sure dr. Gordon won't follow suit
discount Deadpool in x-men origins
Wolverine Elijah Wood it's people
screaming and bleeding from multiple
orifices so it must be saw also this
random scene gives us a character we
won't see again for another hour and
we'll have totally forgotten about by
the time we do see him no wonder no one
can tell the saw sequels apart you have
to wait almost 10 minutes for a title
screen you know which one you're
watching won't be needing this cinema
world what is it with this guy by the
way he did this in the last movie too
somehow this robot camera knows it's in
a horror movie and make sure the footage
comes with a healthy dose of static so
that it can make dramatic reveals Carrie
did this dude go to cop school if we
didn't everything wrong with officer
Riggs cop training it would take three
videos and 15 send counters to cover the
mistakes also how many people watching
this a year from the last movie even
know who Carrie is anymore oh well at
least detective Kerry's body only
attracted one rat somebody get those
rats off her no seriously it's just one
rat on loan from The Departed what agent
Strahm must already know that detective
Hoffman is behind this because he's
being Dickie McDonald addicted for no
good reason
jigsaw is he the murderer the police say
he is also this could be the worst title
ever the name you lead with is jigsaw
and not John Kramer you wouldn't write a
book called David Berkowitz let's just
waste book cover space until we finally
get to Son of Sam he couldn't come up
with a better name than modern cultures
sounds a lot more like an art magazine
than something that would do
depth expose on a mass murder who's he
lieutenant regards what commander what's
his problem I'm gonna go with that crime
scene you just came from didn't sit too
well with him seriously did Darren Lynn
Bausman take Scott Patterson aside and
say you're doing great but I need you to
turn the dick up to at least 257 I guess
I don't expect the cop who takes off his
equipment too early or tries to run into
a room that could be booby-trapped
to be at the top of his game but after
his partners Eric Matthews and Alison
Carey got killed he doesn't seem to be
on the highest alert for potential
kidnapping scenarios this article
actually starts with something about
John Kramer but then proceeds to talk
about a war in Prague or some a man are
you even going to be the least bit
scared about something coming to kidnap
you if you know anything about the
killings you should have set up a
barricade alarms and those traps from
the collector all around your apartment
by now in an unconventional crossover
The Riddler has now joined jigsaws quest
- what exactly is jigsaw doing again
despite seeing jigsaw and his crew pull
off impossible remote TV power ups in
the past this one required a cord
attached to a doorknob to do the trip
and yes if it powered on I don't know
where we would have seen that -
obsession to stop those around you from
making the wrong choices thus preventing
you from making the right ones under
these circumstances how are you not
obsessed with finding the killer we find
out later this is really about rig
running through unsecured doors which i
think could have been handled through
disciplinary action but why not make him
run through some death traps I reckon my
fuse is still alive man Eric Matthews
has to be the saddest sack in the
history of horror movies it makes the
woman in Jurassic world that the
pterodactyls played catch with look like
she got off easy so this is 90 minutes
from win how is it even remotely
possible the jigsaw nose rig will wake
up exactly 90 minutes before the ice
melts under Mathews and yes I realize
this isn't the jigsaw
however the franchise surround with time
and killers identities so many times I'm
just sticking with jigsaw TV powers on I
don't know where so we're sitting that
dude can't he just shoot the hair jigsaw
new rig was going to open that drawer
I feel like this franchise truly went
south when it put in jigsaw disciples
who didn't know the rules of jigsaw
tests and they made the traps
inescapable because at this point the
movies are as cynical as their annual
release date promising sickening death
and little else this chick's hair has
been pulled for good two minutes now how
is she not dead or bald or whatever the
point of this trap is yet yes
not now not now is becoming them I knew
you're late in movies it's pointless
it's probably one of the most dickheaded
things you can tell a cop who obviously
is concerned about something and it's
pointless and stupid and pointless hello
Brenda an officer will try to save you
so did she listen to this message while
I'm tied to the hair-pulling machine
how did she reach it when it was taped
to her hand and she was chained to the
chair also did she remind the tape when
she was done this man we use these
photos to sentence you for your crimes
is she a prostitute does the movie
really tell you do you care so they took
her time to give Matthews a walking boot
for his broken foot they couldn't give
him a bath or shave in the last six
months
previously on saw wait is this - there
was a three there's a boat me I started
when did it ever end can someone explain
the point of painting something that
only a black light can pick up here but
painting a normal a spleen is day here
damn limp Biskit concerts got really
ultra terrible in 2007 be careful we are
a cameras watching and you must hide
your identity good the new jigsaw have
given him these instructions before he
walked into the motel what good is a
disguise when all the cameras have
picked him up already and this asshole
puts on the mask and decides half who
needs this I'll walk through this motel
with my gun drawn and no masks on this
dude kicks the drunk homeless guy out
but then leaves the door wide open takes
a motto and twists it into some manic
torture mantra this guy he really thinks
he's cracked the case
rolling up those sleeves he thinks
John's ex-wife put pictures of herself
all around the crime scene and painted
the clinic's motto on the walls
it's the Basic Instinct alibi the one
you can't even define as an alibi
because it's so stupid I'll have to
convince everybody just 12 people this
big guy you see this space it's John
Kramer buys a house documentaries way
more compelling now that I know he turns
into a serial killer this old-ass TV can
pick up a live broadcast of Eric
Matthews beamed in on my favorite
Channel 68 and 3/4 located between the
zebra and the piccolo on the UHF dial it
is your choice if you wish to put it
into his own this dude did some terrible
but it's really entertaining the idea of
torturing this guy when he's desperately
looking for Eric Matthews right now
without you this
dansgame cannot begin force him into
position to face his demons I like I'll
new jigsaw fix when you've got one
person involved in a game have them help
you set up for someone else's game it's
truly the gift that keeps on giving
I mean he didn't even need to put that
guy in the torture device to get this
message can we have some semblance of
game logic in this movie also why did
this message say only become the teacher
and save a life in this shot and then
add a whole extra phrase in this shot
things people never do when they're
suspected of child abuse this police
report has nothing to do with jigsaw I'm
sorry do you know anything about the
Chinese zodiac hell you've just
mentioned Gideon like he'd know
immediately who that was and then when
he asks you start going into Chinese
zodiac stuff just telling who giddy it
is prostitute hangs around clinic for
that sweet sweet Clinic patient money
I'm glad the writers decided to keep up
the continuity about how no one in this
universe knows how to use a key I know
Cecil told her to stay there but the
other door isn't locked and that would
appear to be the exit where her husband
is closed really what these flashbacks
do is prequel eyes the sequels by
explaining way too much of John's psyche
before he became jigsaw how did he
arrive but this philosophy is
meaningless now since he's dead and his
other disciples aren't following the
rules and the rules have murky
guidelines as it is okay let's review
know we just did that girl loves boy boy
loves girl boy gets girl pregnant girl
loses baby boy turns into a serial
killer this is also known as the circle
of life this wasn't about Rigg saving
his friends it's being recruited
so now Strom thinks Rigg is being
recruited Strom doesn't actually do any
detective work he just stares angrily it
and then shout something that sounds
intelligible
you jump off that block you electrocute
Hamel so I'll point this gun at him to
illustrate how careless you're being
also I'm wondering something
Eric Matthews is so gung-ho about not
giving a fuck what would have happened
if they discovered that Hoffman's trap
didn't work at all
what Hoffman just shoot them in the head
and bounce rig conveniently had a
flashback that would later pay off and a
flashback that Hoffman has also the
Matthews appears to have nothing to do
with any of this other than Rigg wants
to find him so why keep Matthews aligned
for six months for this end game did
Hoffman know he was going to put Rigg
through this six months ago why not just
use his wife I'm beginning to think this
whole series should have been called
flashbacks or just playing flash for
short
copyright be damned the message Rigg got
told him to become the teacher and save
a life and to go where it all began and
he immediately thought I know it's at
that school were folks that teacher also
movie covers so much of the same ground
we just saw a minute ago it's
practically muddin through its plot
right now this clock serves as a
reminder that Rick has wasted nearly an
hour which would be a frantic search for
his partner it also serves as a reminder
that you should never watch the movie
nick of time how the do they wake up
exactly when he arrives you can't time
this plus a jump-scare in a Saw movie is
like a dick in a toaster just doesn't
belong hold on while I try and come up
with a bitter simile so whoever is
behind all this setup spikes that hit
all his major arteries and missed hers I
guess since we find out dr. Gordon from
the first movie is behind a lot of these
traps he could have done this but think
about this for a second he was able to
accurately shoot rods through these
people with their clothes on and he was
able to shoot these things through two
bodies with a crude machine that I guess
has some sort of hyper accurate GPS on
it and the writers room for these movies
must have been a barrel of laughs saw
what these movies are edited with yeah
say yourself I'm so confused
the hard part with the spikes is over
this is just a key how hard is it to put
a key in the harness and unlock her from
this thing past Riggs judgment got fixed
to get her freedom back Strom really
can't stick with a theory yeah second
address why are they looking for the
second address remember this guy our
planes got a bunch of properties last
known address it's a couple blocks from
here how would you know he has a bunch
of properties but not know all the
addresses of said property
[Music]
also was the guy dusting a loaded
crossbow they must have gotten the
backup CSI crew so their where's the
lair jigsaw wanted us to find that place
where's the new game being played find
what place this place but agent Perez
just said it didn't exist like we're
supposed to know what that means
these agents go through so much
information and talk so fast it's like
cinemasins trying to explain what they
think is going on in Terminator Genisys
keep in mind the scene also happens
immediately after one of their forensics
team gets shot in the face with a spike
agent Strahm is surprised to find out he
has a partner agent Perez who was always
by his side
hello arrest lucky for team jigsaw the
correct FBI agent found the tape when it
could have been any number of officers
at the crime scene or some random
homeless person looking for a place to
crash this throws around the office
scene is brought to you by weird
subliminal cuts of agent Perez as if we
needed to know what strom was angry
about yes I want to give you some happy
news wedding back on and major discovery
in bay at dam lair ask questions gives
few answers though I'm just gonna take
down a bunch of random pictures and I'm
sure that will help me solve the case
there really are hundreds of hours of
interview footage with her I'm guessing
all of these questions have been asked
and answered and he is your lawyer
during this flash sequence are we
supposed to believe agent Strahm
actually pulled a gun on Jill or is this
just him imagining it like how these
movies keep showing dr. Lawrence
Gordon's name and never show you Cary
Elwes because apparently they can't pay
him to remind you who the father
Lawrence Gordon is I want to play a game
much like Kanye West John likes to
listen to his own greatest hits while at
home so did Cecil not go to jail he
stole a bunch of drugs and killed a
woman's unborn child I wouldn't think
that was his first offense either John's
first victim was Cecil the guy
responsible for his wife losing the baby
it is finally important to tell you that
he was walking around a street festival
that day and to show you all the
costumes and fireworks I don't really
know why either I'm just a journalist
I'll give the writers credit they are
doing their best at including jigsaw in
a movie when he is now dead but this is
all the same flashback crap that was the
least interesting aspect of the last two
movies as a drug addict and a thief
you've preyed on the kindness of others
so it was John just memorizing the
speech that he was playing back on the
tape recorder a minute ago there's a
drug user and a hustler who played
roulette with other people's alive
actually you know we didn't do a very
good job memorizing that did he or was
this for someone else and he decided to
do the live show for Cecil press hard
enough and your release they offer like
restraints or you can sit idly and bleed
out but couldn't he still bleed out even
if he gets out of the trap he would then
be bleeding from his face as well four
walls build a home he has looked at this
damn article I don't know how many times
and he is just now noticing the big ass
bold letters that say four walls build a
home you movie is it I guess this guy
wasn't super unlikable enough already so
they added this team I don't have two
minutes why wait two minutes for backup
when you can go in by yourself - what's
probably a well-executed jigsaw trap
[Music]
this just seems like overkill why did
art have to go through one test only to
be thrust into yet another test one that
completely relies on some asshole not
walking through the door man I just
wants all three and I can't even
remember who this is also saw three is
happening at the same time as saw four
with perfect in sync timing somehow just
think if agent Strahm figures out the
four walls build a home clue sooner both
movies get derailed
can art not at least answer Matthews
question what's it gonna hurt this guy
is about to have his head squash by two
huge blocks of ice that somehow haven't
melted yet he couldn't have run up to
the door and told rigged to hold on for
10 seconds art is useless well at least
Eric doesn't have to watch any more Saw
movies so the prediction that Strom
would kill an innocent man happens right
here but Jeff did point a gun at him and
he did slash jigsaws throat so I don't
know if we're splitting hairs here but
he's not terribly innocent also I
thought at the end of saw three John
played a tape explaining to Jeff that he
had to play a game to save his daughter
but I guess this movie forgot that and
Jeff just demands answers from any
asshole who runs into a room
pretty sure often playing on it since he
was trying to teach her a lesson about
running through doors like this but the
problem here is after 90 minutes blank
was going to be able to release Matthews
and himself from the trap regardless of
whether Rigg came through the door or
not what lesson does Rigg learn if he
still bust down the door but the 90
minutes were up and nobody dies
I would have probably said something
like I need to get this tape recorder so
Rick doesn't shoot me art hello officer
rank if you are hearing this good thing
art was able to take the time to press
play while his brains were shooting out
of his head
seriously how did no one suspect Hoffman
this entire time just look at him for
Christ's sake we call this look the
Costas Mandalore we're here to find the
person helping jigsaw and Amanda young
by the way with this movie in psalm
three happening at the same time how
does the FBI know anything about Amanda
young being in on this at the end of saw
two I don't believe there was anything
tying her to jigsaw even if the cops
were studying the tapes even her
recording to Erick hasn't been found and
this plan worked out to perfection for
detective Hoffman remember the only
reason why agent Strahm is here right
now is because he had a last-minute
revelation about the gideon meat-packing
plant great timing also one day he's
gonna kill an innocent man thing because
that doesn't happen if Strom doesn't get
a last-second out of his ass League see
I think the giveaway in these films is
that anyone who knows how to properly
use a key is a killer you think it's
over just because I am dead
damn you Wesley what went wrong was that
the Rous is also where did the guys
doing the autopsy go
you would think Hoffman would be smart
enough to listen to this tape somewhere
else it's not over the games have just
begun
if the 27 games that were just going on
at the same time weren't enough for you
I am your father's brother's nephews
cousins former roommate which wash the
hair in his something now he's smart mr.
jingles this is what we call an orgy of
evidence
you know Tammy hardly zop kill us if he
got a chance just a flesh wound just a
bit outside he tried the corner in this
her life is in her hands her life is in
your hands mr. Lebowski asked me to
repeat that boom goes the dynamite